hey crazies I don't know if you've
noticed there's something weird about
the night sky there are bright dots
everywhere
most of them are very far away and stay
pretty static relative to each other
which is why for thousands of years we
were convinced they formed a solid shell
around us faithfully we've learned that
space has a lot more depth than that but
in this narrow band across the sky
you'll find the closest ducts
these are super weird because there's
some of the brightest in the sky and if
you watch long enough you can see them
move against the background
those bright wandering dots are the
planets which comes from the ancient
Greek planet AES theories meaning
wandering star acne in ancient Greek the
now cometh before the adjective so it
would be a series planet a or star
wandering whatever it doesn't matter the
point is all the planets the Sun and the
moon are in the same part of the sky
it's called the ecliptic because it's
where all the solar and lunar eclipses
happen that band also happens to pass
through twelve star constellations
called the zodiac sight note
constellations are completely arbitrary
groups of stars made up by people
thousands of years ago probably with the
help of psychotropic drugs dude I think
it looks like a lion astrology is a form
of magic from 4000 years ago
astronomy is a completely respectable
science and science is what we do here
and of sidenote so to understand why all
these things are along the ecliptic we
need to think three dimensionally the
orbit of the earth around the Sun is
called the plane of the ecliptic how
much another orbit is tilted from that
plane is called its inclination for the
other seven planets and the moon those
inclination ZAR less than 10 degrees
that means they all orbit in roughly the
same plane but why what's the deal with
that hmm that's a good question
this is only gonna make sense if we go
back to the beginning to the time
machine
five billion years ago the solar system
was just a giant cloud of gas and dust
and gravity had begun to pull it in
causing it to collapse as the cloud got
smaller the particles of gas and dust
started to bump into each other more
often over the course of about 50
million years those collisions took
their toll
most of
a random up and down motions of those
particles canceled out leaving only the
overall spin of the clouds it's now what
we call an accretion disk which will
eventually form the planets over the
next few hundred million years back to
the lab so that's it
conservation of momentum turns the cloud
into a plane before the planets even
form I have had it with muffin planets
in a mother plane so why wasn't the Sun
at the center of that cloud also a disc
the gas and dust got too close too fast
remember turning that cloud into a disc
took millions of years by that time
ninety-nine point eight percent of the
matter in that cloud had already fallen
into the center the Sun was already on
its way to forming long before it had a
chance to flatten out if matter is very
loosely packed then one piece can travel
a long way before it runs into another
piece that's what it looks like in the
accretion disk
however if matter is tightly packed and
held in place by gravity then the pieces
can't get away from the collisions
they're stuck but that doesn't mean they
don't try and that causes a net outward
pressure in all directions which forms a
sphere not a disc but isn't it still
trying to flatten out a little bit right
select with most things it's the
spectrum there are two factors at work
at the same time outward pressure from
the collisions and angular momentum from
the spin if the matter is loose angular
momentum dominates and you get a disc if
the matter is dense outward pressure
dominates and you get a sphere the
angular momentum is always there though
so even things like the Sun and the
earth bulge at their equator a little
bit most asteroids and comets tend to be
sort of in the awkward in-between -
tends to be a disc but too light to be a
sphere so they turned out lumpy so
what's the weirdest thing you've ever
seen in the sky please share in the
comments thanks for liking and sharing
this video please subscribe if you'd
like to keep up with us and until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy
in the last video we learned how planes
fly come in response time to Schaumburg
all in 1598 we're both wondering how
planes actually move forward good
question airplanes have very powerful
engines that turn big turbines or
propellers the blades of those engines
pull the air backwards so hard that the
plane responds by moving forward also
conservation of momentum rolling on the
floor laughing my stuff PMP q XYZ
suggested that Newton's third law was a
better explanation well yes Newton's
third law is a valid explanation if
you're careful but I wouldn't say it's
better per se it's about the same for an
airplane technically you can get
conservation of momentum from Newton's
third law but you can also get Newton's
third law from conservation of momentum
there's no way to claim that either one
is more fundamental than the other it
comes down to how your brain works and
what you're used to when you do a lot of
advanced physics like I do things like
Einstein's relativity in quantum physics
you find that Newton's laws aren't
nearly as useful as conservation laws so
I'm just in the habit of thinking in
terms of conservation laws plus I think
they're a little more elegant for deeper
understanding rogue assassin gaming was
mind-blown by me saying air was a fluid
air is a fluid in fact any substance
that is capable of flowing is called a
fluid basically any substance whose
molecules can move about freely that
includes both liquids and gases and if
you think about it air and water behave
in a lot of the same ways water is just
so dense you can see it that's all Joe
Craig wants to know how to use science
to take over the world
I wouldn't ever reveal my secrets
muah-muah anyway thanks for watching
I'll see you next time